your papers please says igor mangushev
he and his men from a self-appointed
militia group sift through a dilapidated
house in the middle of moscow
without any legal authority migrants
from central asia are thought to be
hiding here
they are a source of cheap labor often
without valid
we are from the presnya district militia
keep your documents ready and wait for
the police
mangushev and his men do this week after
week
residents tip them off as to where
migrants could be living
many think immigrants are a problem for
moscow
my papers are in order this man tells me
he's mistaken
for a member of the militia
i ask him where he's from
uzbekistan he says you came here for
work i ask
yes he says here in moscow there are
jobs
at home it's difficult
now he is desperate mangushev has called
the police
and that means the man from uzbekistan
will probably be deported
this has nothing to do with nationalism
says
it's about different civilizations
central asia is a region where
fundamentally different rules apply than
in moscow
they don't make the slightest effort to
accept our russian rules or to integrate
here
a survey by the last remaining
independent russian polling organization
shows that many people in moscow think
like this
about 80 percent of muscovites want the
immigrants from central asia to be sent
home
but it would be hard to imagine moscow's
construction boom without them
on many of the building sites it's
migrants who do the hard labor
and at this construction site on the
outskirts of the russian capital
they have now gone on strike
from tajikistan and his team have gone
more than three months without pay
they are owed a total of more than 100
000 euros
but the man from the construction
company dimitri yarosh
says he knows nothing about it there's
probably not much morado and his workers
from tajikistan can do
they can't bring those responsible to
account
that really shouldn't be happening we'll
have to clarify that with our
subcontractors
who hired these people as a general
contractor we do not employ any
construction workers we hire a company
it pays its people and it must also
provide accommodation for them
the tajik workers live in containers
directly on the construction site
and mouradov says they have to pay for
it the equivalent of around 70 euros per
month
he wants to show me how they live and
leads me around the grounds
cooking eating sleeping they have
everything they need
in the containers
some workers even live here with their
families and small children
none of them could afford to rent a real
apartment they only earn about
800 euros a month if they get paid at
all
times have got tougher muradov says
what do they still need us for i've now
been here in russia for over 10 years
and we've built a lot everywhere you
look now perhaps it's
enough for them maybe they now want to
chase us away
hundreds of thousands of migrant workers
live in moscow
some estimate there are about two
million they work in construction
as cleaners or nannies as taxi drivers
or street sweepers
and many are traders in the big outdoor
markets
when they see that i'm filming here many
become nervous
time and again nationalists have
attacked markets like this
now the mood has changed even among
ordinary muscovites
hostility towards those who do not look
russian is growing
the citizens aid organization has been
observing this for a long time
irina elena and her colleagues provide
advice and medical help to migrants and
refugees
this young man from uzbekistan was
brutally attacked and robbed by a group
of russians
he was about to transfer money to his
family at home
money he earns as a tailor in moscow
this activist translates the young man's
story
he says the young man was tied up and
driven to a forest where he was beaten
he feels migrants can be often attacked
with impunity in russia nowadays
the media are now constantly he says
almost hysterically reporting about
immigrants
this probably influences people and that
leads to this kind of harassment
this is probably the main reason
irena gets 30 to 40 calls for help every
day
the aggression migrants face is greater
than ever
the social worker and human rights
activist says the hatred is directed
toward
all migrants sometimes it's against
caucasians from chechnya or dagestan
people who are russian citizens
there's also hatred targeted at refugees
from far away countries who look
different
like people from africa who've come to
seek asylum
and it's aimed at economic migrants
she shows me videos on the internet to
help me understand
why the atmosphere has now become so
charged
the pictures she shows me are from
mid-october
in southern moscow an angry mob storms a
market
the workers here come mainly from the
caucasus and central asia
a few days earlier a young muscovite had
been stabbed to death in broad daylight
there were reports a man who looked like
he was from the caucasus was to blame
and there were rumors he was hiding at
the market
the police were slow to stop the rioters
but the next day they arrested about a
thousand migrants
to prevent further violence the
authorities said
irina says that's always the way
she says the government encourages
migrants
it recently came up with an immigration
policy in black and white it said russia
needs
labor migrants in this country the birth
rate is catastrophically low she says
it'll need plenty of manpower in the
future
i am surprised that russia has gone so
long without a clear
immigration policy immigrants from the
former soviet republics in central asia
can come to russia without a visa
and stay for three months but many stay
longer and work
illegally at their own risk or because
their employer bribes the authorities
migrant workers are used to having no
rights
authorities say there are more than
three and a half million
undocumented immigrants in russia the
real numbers are probably
much higher whenever public anger
reaches boiling point
they are the scapegoats and then there
are official raids
inspections and waves of deportations
but usually nothing happens mangushev
says
that was why he and his friends decided
to take the fight against illegal
immigration into their own hands
they've been doing this for the past two
years they have carried out more than
100 raids and filmed
everything igor manguchev shows me
pictures of their last major action
they tracked down several dozen
immigrants and handed them over to the
authorities
they often force their way into the
hiding places
go go get your documents out igor
manguchev calls out in this video
all this is completely legal he says
after all they call the police as soon
as they find
migrant workers here they discovered 45
immigrants
and illegal drugs and numerous
electronics
drug trafficking and petty crime these
are the usual accusations against
immigrants
has called in the special police forces
for help
wearing helmets and bulletproof vests
they lead away the defenseless migrants
thinks he did the right thing
he says there are only two possibilities
either the problem will be solved from
the ground up with his group's help
or it will be the end of the political
system the disintegration of russia
religious and national conflicts have
long reached the boiling point he says
goes back into the night with his
militia
the police were suspicious of them at
first he says
many officials profited from immigrants
fears
they would provide cover for the
illegals in exchange for a fat bribe
but now many police officers are working
together with the vigilantes
they can't stop immigration but
igor mangushev and his men are
succeeding
in stirring up xenophobia and conflict
in russia